good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we often accuse
politicians of dishonesty on this show
but there are grades of it let's boil it
down
nothing the democratic party advocates
for is more dishonest than
gun control everything about that one
specific issue
is false most policy debates actually
aren't like that and we try to be honest
about it on the show no matter how
passionate you are about a position that
you have
you can still sort of see what the other
side is talking about
you might for example deeply dislike
taxes but you can still acknowledge it
is fair to charge people for the
services they receive from the
government
so this side isn't crazy they just
arrived at a different number than you
did
or you can hate abortion and we do and
you can still understand if again if
you're being totally honest about it why
a scared pregnant teenager
might be tempted to have one but gun
control is not
like that gun control is entirely
fraudulent
the democratic party claims that guns
cause violence that's the core claim and
it is a lie
it is provably untrue the places in this
country that have the most guns
and the loosest controls on those guns
also have
the least gun violence the fewest
killings that's the bottom line
you can look it up it's publicly
available to anyone
anyone who tries to restrict your
legally owned firearms is
not trying to make america safer the
point
is to disarm you to strip you of your
autonomy your power
your right of self-defense gun control
is not
about guns gun control is about who
controls
america is it the population as in a
democracy
or does all control go to a small group
of authoritarians as in an
oligarchy those are the stakes in the
gun control debate
it's not about guns it's about who runs
the country
so with that in mind joe biden's speech
today calling for more gun control
should make you uncomfortable almost
nothing biden said was true we could go
down the list but here are a few
highlights to give you the flavor
biden claim that firearms purchased at
gun shows are exempt from background
checks
that's a lie as anyone who's ever been
to a gun show can tell you
joe biden claimed that gun manufacturers
have total immunity against lawsuits
that's also a lie gun manufacturers get
sued all the time
ask them etc so it was a speech aimed to
mislead
rather than to inform before he
announced how he plans to restrict your
second amendment rights
joe biden wanted to remind you that
those rights are not real in the first
place
they are not as he put it absolute
nothing i'm about to recommend in any
way impinges on the second amendment
they're phony arguments suggesting that
these are second amendment rights at
stake for what we're talking about
but no amendment no amendment to the
constitution is absolute
you heard the sirens in the background
responding to the
skyrocketing crime rate in the city he
presides over
but the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be
infringed that's the promise in the u.s
constitution but according to joe biden
it's still not an absolute right despite
what the text says no
that right is subject to his approval
and his interpretation
joe biden is in charge of the
constitution now joe biden
defines its terms and joe biden has
decided that something called
stabilizing braces
can no longer be allowed now a
stabilizing brace is used by target
shooters to hold heavy firearms
they play zero role in the murder
epidemic now underway in our cities
then why is joe biden banning them
without the approval of congress
probably because up to 40 million law
abiding americans
own this device and under this order joe
biden's order
every one of those people will have to
alert federal authorities
and pay hundreds of dollars in fines for
the crime
of owning a harmless piece of plastic
that was legal yesterday
and if they don't comply joe biden's
federal authorities can then drag them
off in handcuffs seize their property
and charge them with a felony
so with a single stroke of a pen joe
biden just turned
tens of millions of overwhelmingly
republican voters
into criminals is it starting to make
sense now
think about that for a minute and you'll
begin to understand why the democratic
party is so focused on what they call
weapons of war you might know them as
semi-automatic small caliber sporting
rifles that normal people use for
hunting and target shooting and home
defense
here's the thing that you should know
and again don't take our word for it
look it up
no subject is more carefully cataloged
than gun violence
guns like this these so-called weapons
of war play no
meaningful role in crime virtually all
gun murders in this country are
committed with handguns
a small number of people again provable
a small number of people are responsible
for most of the violence and they use a
small variety of weapons to commit it
those weapons are not rifles here are
the numbers
according to the most recent data from
the fbi firearms were involved in a
total of 10
258 homicides in 2019 the last year for
which data are available
fewer than 500 out of more than 10 000
of those homicides were committed with
rifles rifles of all kinds
including so-called weapons of war so
criminals don't use
rifles they're not concealable maybe
that's why in fact
more people were murdered with knives
than with rifles
so if you actually cared about making
the country safer keeping people from
getting murdered
you would target handguns in big cities
that's where the murders are that's
where the violence is but the bide
administration is doing
the opposite of this the mirror image of
this
the biden administration is letting big
city criminals
go people who use guns for violence are
walking out of jail
and instead the bide administration is
using you saw today the full force of
government to disarm
peaceful voters in zip codes that voted
for donald trump
it is that simple today biden announced
that he wants to ban what he calls
assault weapons he's speaking about the
ar-15
which is the single most popular
sporting rifle in america
so the question is if we banned
so-called assault weapons would the
country become
safer that's the only question that
matters and we don't need to guess about
the answer because we've tried this
before
under bill clinton for 10 full years we
banned assault rifles and then by law
the department of justice studied the
effects
so we know the effect and you again can
look it up if you want
it didn't work in fact once that ban
expired in 2004
gun homicides fell in almost every major
city
so policies like this one are unhinged
from reality to put it gently so to
enforce them
joe biden has nominated a man who was
unhinged from reality his name is david
chipman
and he will now run the bureau of
alcohol tobacco and firearms an agency
that joe biden referred to today
as the aft
today i am proud to nominate
david chipman to serve as the director
of the aft
david knows aft well
david knows aft well hilarious if you're
joe biden everything is a teacher's
union
the aft is a teacher's union so who is
david chipman
well he's a conspiracy nut for one thing
in a recent internet post on reddit he
claimed that the branch davidian
shot down helicopters during the waco
siege in 1993. no they didn't
no one aboard a federal helicopter was
shot or injured that day the helicopters
didn't crash
that is a bizarre claim to make from
someone who was directly involved in the
case as david chipman was
but it's worse than that in 1993 the atf
killed dozens of innocent children
and at least one pregnant woman for no
obvious reason
it's one of the worst things that
federal agents have ever done in this
country
so if you're taking over the atf maybe
you could apologize for that but no
david chipman lied about it and then
attacked the dead
it was like blaming the japanese for
their own internment or attacking the
victims of the zizki
experiment for getting syphilis it was
not evidence of a generous spirit it was
evidence of a zealot
this is the man joe biden just nominated
to lead atf but it gets worse than that
in a reddit post david chipman suggested
that people who fail background checks
should be arrested on the spot
quote while at atf i conducted studies
involving people who failed background
checks to determine how many later
committed crimes with a gun many did
this is a perfect opportunity to arrest
people before committing crimes
rather than responding after the fact
arrest people
before they commit crimes that is a
brand new concept
in american law though the chinese are
highly familiar with it
but the suggestion does raise a point of
pressing interest to the biden family
joe biden just appointed a guy who
thinks people who lie on federal
firearms background checks should go to
prison
oh well do you know any hunter biden
purchased a handgun illegally he lied on
a federal background check that's not
speculation he did we've seen the form
so the question is will david chipman
arrest the president's son
and if he doesn't arrest the president's
son the question is
how exactly are you obligated to follow
these rules
that's a serious question can you live
in a country where the rules don't apply
to the president's son but you could go
to jail for violating them how can you
participate in a system like that
again sincere question they should
explain
we should note that david chipman has
said a lot of other things on the
internet that he doesn't want you to see
he's locked his twitter account so that
nobody can read it
but the daily wire found an archived
version of his twitter page and compared
it to his current page
they found that david chipman deleted at
least a thousand tweets in recent days
and we can only speculate about what he
said in those posts we do know that what
he said publicly
tells us all we need to know about how
we got this job
in october 2018 for example david
chipman told the hill
that ar-15 should be treated quote just
like machine guns
well machine guns are banned in this
country he believes ar-15s the single
most popular rifle in america
should be banned chipman made that
remark in his capacity as a policy
advisor for an anti-gun group one of the
many
funded by michael bloomberg in 2012 he
suggested msnbc that the secret service
shouldn't carry firearms
and last year david chipman openly
mocked the millions of americans who
were buying firearms
to protect their families from the crime
wave that david chipman's
party has unleashed on the country
they might think that they're die hard
ready to go
but unfortunately they're more like
tiger king and
they're putting themselves and their
families in danger
and so what i would suggest is for those
people who were first-time gun owners if
they did
go out and buy a gun um i would secure
that gun
locked and unloaded and hide it behind
the cans of tuna and beef jerky that
you've stored in a cabinet
and you know only bring that out if the
zombies start to appear
and i don't think they are
it's hard to imagine a flippant remark
that's more infuriating than that one
if you bought a gun to protect your
family your business your home during
the riots that these people
unleashed on the country a conspiracy
nut running the atf
calls you crazy that's why if you made
the mistake of buying a handgun with a
magazine that holds more than 10 rounds
in other words if you bought a glock
19 or any of the most popular handguns
sold in america
you'll be obligated to surrender it to
that guy
and high capacity means what kind of
numbers are we talking about
yeah so i think the consensus has been
around 10.
um and there are a number of reasons why
10 and above would be high
yeah well i think let's say 10 and below
are okay
or reasonable above would be regulated
so this raises a lot of questions why is
david chipman allowed to decide how many
rounds you're allowed in your magazine
what does he know about that is he in
charge of protecting your family does he
live in your neighborhood
are your children his responsibility
it's outrageous
but worse than that is theater it's not
real people like david chipman aren't
opposed to gun violence
in fact people like david chipman his
party certainly are making gun violence
possible in this country we could give
you many examples we have for years
here's a new one in washington the city
is planning to stop enforcing gun laws
really the party that thinks guns cause
violence is no longer pulling them off
the street why because it's racially
insensitive to do that
a d.c police commander called john
haynes just sent a memo announcing this
policy quote
no longer are we focused on getting guns
huh aren't they telling us out of the
other side of their mouth that your guns
are their problem
right your guns not the criminals guns
your guns because
you're the criminal now meanwhile in
chicago where a 21 month old child was
just shot
on the street last month mayor lori
lightfoot has decided that
not all guns need to be removed from the
streets no just the ones that you won't
according to lori lightfoot the real
danger is not handguns it's quote
military-grade weapons from other states
tuesday little cayden swann was shot on
lake shore drive
18 others were shot five of them died
wednesday mayor lori lightfoot said part
of the crime issue
is gun control if you can go over the
border in indiana
and literally buy military grade weapons
with any
at any quantity cpd numbers show that
crime is up
around this time last year there were
521 people
shot now that number is 743.
this is this is one of those topics
that's hard to do on tv
because in about an hour you can learn
more about this topic
actual facts about this topic that every
single person making the policy
everything they say is untrue and
provably so
there's no issue in which they lie more
than this one which tells you a lot
lori lightfoot statement the one you
just saw is a shocking lie
in chicago's own data prove it most
violent crimes in illinois were
committed with guns purchased in the
state
according to chicago police from 2018 to
2019
authorities encountered a grand total of
how many people armed with
military-grade rifles or all rifles
four four people in the whole city in a
year with rifles
that's it and that's what lori lightfoot
is focused on
in that same period they encountered 44
people armed with revolvers
they encountered 15 people armed with
chemical weapons whatever that is and
there were 32 people wielding their feet
in a violent manner and the rest of
course were semi-automatic handguns
that's all the murders are committed
with and everyone knows it
rifles are not a real threat in chicago
and they haven't been for a long time if
ever
between 2013 and 2016 just 4.8 percent
of guns recovered by the chicago police
were rifles
4.8 percent the most recent murder
report from chicago is from all the way
back in 2011 they're a little slow on
the numbers there
but according to that report just one
rifle
was used in a homicide in the city of
chicago one
and that's what they want to take away
why because you own it
not the criminals in the decade that
followed george soros funded d.a called
kim foxx took over in chicago and during
her tenure
prosecutors started dropping cases for
serious gun crimes not accidentally
but as a matter of policy they
intentionally dropped gun crimes
aggravated battery with a firearm
unlawful use of a weapon reckless
discharge with firearm aggravated
discharge
serious crimes involving guns they drop
the charges
they're not worried about gun crime
they're worried about you protecting
yourself
and not just in chicago across the
country criminals who commit violence
with guns are going free
murder rates are hitting record levels
meanwhile you haven't heard anyone
you haven't done anything wrong but
suddenly hunter biden has a fat book
contract from simon
schuster and you're a felon for trying
to defend your home you can see what's
going on here
again they're not trying to control guns
they're trying to control you